startup dream fold his uh as a PhD
student supervised by yosua Benjo and
sarth chander his research interests
span generative modeling and
probabilistic inference with
applications to protein binder
design and he will tell us about practic
practical side the Practical side of
training
gonet thanks CA um hi everybody
so I'm going to talk about what Co said
I'm going to talk about so let's talk
about it um okay so g- Nets g-l Nets are
an interesting thing we've talked about
there's a lot of parallels or there's a
lot of connections between RL generative
modeling and G Nets these come in forms
like coia mentioned earlier there's deep
connections between variational
inference and gon Nets and in particular
the way we train gonets is very similar
to reinforcement
learning in reinforcement learning right
we have an mdp we take steps
sequentially and we get rewards over
time in g-l Nets we do about the same
thing we have some mdp something which
is
saying at least in the SCP space we have
an MP something that's saying from this
state I can take these actions and I'm
going to transition to these other
places and specifically at the end of an
episode at the end of a trajectory we
get some reward
um so gener models also not really like
this we train them very differently but
they kind of in a way do a similar thing
um where you have data set instead of
having uh not a data set um but you
train them to match uh a target
distribution and specifically in the
variational inference case you can
recover some very similar things to what
we do with uh gfl
Nets so as uh Emanuel and Kia already
mentioned there's really a core training
Loop of what we do for G Nets so it's
pretty simple it's it's it's just like
RL right so the first thing we do we
have some policy and we say Okay policy
let's let's generate some experiences so
we get this batch of experiences somehow
and then next we're going to get some
rewards a gonet is all about the
terminal rewards right what gonets do is
they sample objects as Emanuel was
talking about um proportional to the
reward of those objects and so these
objects we say are basically the um the
states we arrive at at the end of a
trajectory um so we generate our batch
of experiences from our forward policy
and we get some rewards for the objects
that these trajectories generated and
then we compute the loss on these
trajectories and so here I'll make a
quick note this uh this notation is a
little bit different I'm saying that
we're sampling a trajectory from the
forward policy which is the same ways of
writing the same thing we had before um
if we recall that a policy is a
markovian policy then the likelihood of
sampling of AA a trajectory is just the
product of all the transitions in the
trajectory so this is the core training
Loop
cool basically the first and third part
are very interchangeable so coio was
already talking about what do we do for
step number three there's a bunch of
different objective functions all these
try to do the same thing in principle
they have we have a set of constraints
for Gil Nets and we want to try to say
that everywhere in space at all
different times these constraints are
satisfied because if we do this then we
get what we want we get a sampler um
that samples objects proportional to the
reward so that's one side of things the
other side of things is how do we
actually choose how do we get the data
that we're going to use to train our G
Nets and so what we're going to focus on
in this talk is specifically how do we
get these this data how do we get the
things that we're going to train our
gonut
on so how do we do this there's two main
levers the first lever um as people have
talked about is how do we generate this
data right so just like an RL um we have
a policy we simulate the policy um to
get back
experiences we can choose how we want to
generate these experiences we can change
our policy we can do different things to
make it more exploratory or maybe make
it focus on specific modes more um and
so we have ultimate Freedom really to
choose how we want to do this this goes
back to one of the core four important
things of G Nets which is that because
of the way the objectives work and the
way the math works out you can train
them off policy you can get samples you
can get data from wherever you want if
you train if you train everywhere you
will get a sampler that does what you
want of course we don't sample
everywhere but the point is you don't
have to sample as in VI as in
variational inference what you typically
or what you might have to do is you
generate things according to the thing
you've already learned and now if you
want to go away from this you have to
import an sample and this is sad we
don't want to do this it's unstable it's
not as fun um but because of the way G
objectives work you don't have to do
this you can sample wherever you want
just as long as you try to satisfy defil
balance or flow matching or trajectory
balance or whatever other balance you're
happy so this is one lever how do we
choose what uh how do we design a policy
how do we get a policy that's going to
help us discover modes which is
important right like this especially as
you scale the problems As you move the
problems from you know the toy like CR
World tasks to really big real world
tasks right like the thing that I'm
interested is protein design and for
some of the proteins that you might want
to generate like they're say 200 lengths
long and there's 20 amino acids so how
big is that that's a search space of 20
to the 200th this is hard to explore
it's just hard and also there's other
hard things right I mean you could
imagine having um a very nons smooth
reward functions which is something that
we want to do sometimes right sometimes
we want what do we really want like if
we're doing a search problem we want to
generate the best things the the best
molecules or the best proteins or the
best Crystal structures um and we want
to generate a diverse set of these but
to get the best ones you have to sample
gilets are going to sample proportional
reward so you might have to make your
reward function rather non-s smooth um
and more peaky to try to um to try to
sample more often the things that are
really good but the more peaky your
distribution is the more likely you
might get you might be to get stuck in
modes and get mode collapse and be sad
so
um we should figure out a good way to do
this and we've done a bunch of things
um the second thing is that now once we
have the data that we've generated how
do we choose even from the data we've
generated which things we actually want
to train on so this is stuff like emanu
was mentioning earlier replay buffers
how do we choose of the data that we
have which things we want to use and
depending on the way we do this you can
see rather significant differences and
how fast you train um but as Emanuel
said with caveats all right so designing
an exploratory policy so let's say we
have a Target policy this is RPF that
we've talked about so far today and this
thing is like your normal G Net policy
right it's trying to um it's going to
try to satisfy detail balance or
trajectory balance and it's going to try
to sample proportional to the reward at
the end of the day so we can also have a
behavior policy just like an RL um whose
job is just to generate samples that are
good for PF to learn on what do we want
we want something that learns the
distribution we want to be able to
sample from R so all we care about is
can we get a behavior policy which is
going to make learning to sample R as
easy it as it can be for the Target
policy
um there's a bunch of considerations
here right but one main thing is we want
to try to have the behavior policy be we
call full support over the uh object
distrib bution so you can imagine if you
do not have full support so what do I
mean like let's say we have this grid
here right and we have a a behavior
policy which ends up kind of saturating
in some way and it only samples the top
left
corner if you show this to a g- phone
it'll be perfectly happy it doesn't care
like it will see I can go to these four
states okay cool I'll learn my Zed and
the trajectory balance to be the
partition function for those four states
I can it'll
um learn PF and PB according to that
partition function and the loss can go
to zero everywhere and the target policy
will never sample anything um besides
those four states so we don't want this
so we want to make sure we sample
everywhere um and as long as we're we
have some likelihood that we're going to
sample everywhere at least in theory
eventually we should converge to um a
true correct G Net policy um of course
this doesn't necessarily happen in
practice but in theory it is true okay
exploration for
chfs okay obvious first try what should
we do let's just take the the current
Target policy but this is dumb don't do
this I mean it could be okay but like in
general it's not great so like I was
saying same thing you could imagine you
have
um like your current Target policy isn't
constrained to to sample from everything
and so we see this happening here we
have this true distribution where it's
very peaky these Corners there's three
corners that have um some reward and the
gilet is going to stop start from the
top left corner and it's perfectly fine
for this gilet to just go and find one
mode and you can pretty easily see I
mean you you can train this yourself and
you'll pretty easily see that the loss
goes to zero but what happens is it just
learns to generate maybe one of the
modes and even with in the mode it's not
even capturing all the other uh states
that are right next to it it's perfectly
fine to just saturate and mode collapse
and this is kind of expected there's uh
there's an interesting little proof in
um the G Net and variational inference
paper which shows that if you learn uh
specifically with trajectory balance um
on policy the gradient you get is the
same as the gradient of the reverse KL
and we know from generative modeling
this is not a good to do the reverse K
has problems with Mo collaps and you see
exactly the same behavior if you do on
policy learning um and G Nets as you
would in RL as well
um so a second try we can do some rather
simple things that interestingly seem to
work in many cases um so just like in RL
we can mix in uniform noise with the
current policy that we're
learning so the most obvious example of
this is to take an Epsilon random policy
just like Epsilon greedy and RL and so
we say that uh with likelihood one minus
Epsilon we're going to sample an action
from the target policy um and with
probability Epsilon we'll just take a
random
action the other version of this is
really the the way that we use GES in
practice is that we uh we as many other
things learn the log in and this gives
us boltzman distribution and so as in
other boltman distributions you can
learn a temperature which controls how
pey or how flat this uh this
distribution becomes and so we can use
this temperature parameter um whereas if
you increase the temperature um if you
yeah if you increase the
temperature the policy becomes more flat
and if you bring that temperature to
zero it becomes very peaky around the
thing that it thinks is best and so one
approach is to just take a
policy and take the uh sorry take the
logits that we learned for the Target
policy and temper the distribution with
some
like value of temperature greater than
one to basically have a slightly more
flat distribution um than the target
policy um and these actually kind of
work rather like surprisingly
well most G Net papers use this to to
date I mean we've run experiments where
at least in small scales for example in
small scale settings these work really
really well like you it's hard to beat
this like in smaller scale settings um
even as you scale like there's an
interesting experiment we did at some
point where we had um it was an RNA
generation task and you have about 20
million States so not near as big as is
you know 20 to the 200th um but 20
million States and with this exploration
the gonet finds every mode that exists
very quickly
um but this has failure cases as you
might expect specifically as the reward
becomes more sparse um so like I was
saying if the reward basically becomes
less smooth um or if the search Bas is
very very very large
these things can start to fail and so
this is um learning with a tempered
policy on the same problem as before um
and just as with an on policy um
distribution or on policy exploration
policy it mode collapses and goes to one
thing
um so how do we avoid this we don't like
this this is sad there's some ways to do
this right I mean you could imagine in
this case right like you could you could
even game it with these right you could
have a fully random policy like this
would be fine this would work you could
have a fully random policy or you could
bring the temperature very very high um
which people also do this is a typical
thing that people do in mcmc for example
for example the replica exchange where
you have many different mcmc chains all
at different temperatures and the higher
temperature ones higher temperature mcmc
chains are more likely to sample
everywhere in the space and you can kind
of mix these things and there is a uh
there's a recent gelet paper that is
doing something similar with temperature
uh with
uh choosing the temperature um of the
tempered
policy um but there's other approaches
that people typically use in RL and
we'll cover briefly two of these
approaches so first something that's
very useful in RL is to try to use
intrinsic rewards to encourage
exploration um so a paper night per 2023
uh tried to do this with gonets and so
basically we use uh a pseudo count to
augment the reward of a terminal State
and so basically we change the reward
such that um for places we have not
visited
um the gonet is incentivized to visit
them more and as it visits more and more
the reward goes down and the gonet is
less likely to sample this so this paper
in particular uses R&D um which is a way
to do pseudo counts in RL um and works
rather well specifically when we have a
very sparse reward so here is uh this
is um two results on the left they take
a very very sparse grid and in this case
the
uh this sort of
intrinsic reward approach works very
well um very similarly for molecules
that use a sparse version of a molecule
task this also works very well um
there's other things you can do right
another RL exploration Paradigm is to
use uncertainty and there's much work on
this direction um and so this also works
in some cases if the um if the search
space is very large or if it is if it is
sparse as well
um and so what you do here is very much
like bootstrap dqn an RL you keep a a
Ensemble of policies at each uh step you
choose a member of The Ensemble and
generate a tra a trajectory according to
this member of The
Ensemble um you can encourage diversity
in multiple uh multiple ways in The
Ensemble with bootstrapping or prior
networks but this is like these are two
versions of these things this is a
general recipe right exploration for G
Nets isn't that much different than an
RL there's many ways to use uncertainty
to um give better ways to explore in RL
there's many ways to use uh intrinsic
rewards there's many ways to do
exploration besides these things in RL
these are all things that probably will
work probably will be very useful they
haven't been tried um and so if people
are interested in this they should try
these are these are good things to try
um so yeah if the exploration problem is
a bit harder if the distribution is
maybe not so um easy to generalize to
for example Thompson sampling works
well um there's other things we can do
say we have a data set say we know some
really good samples we can take a um we
can take one of these really good
examples X and we can simulate a or we
can sample a trajectory from our
backwards policy and train on that
trajectory and this has been very useful
in a bunch of different papers from um
back in 2022 on um energy based modeling
with gfns doing em with gfns also doing
things for um making exporation better
with mcmc this also works there where
for example you take something that is
close to a mode you do a small chain on
it to get a really even better um sample
and then you train on the backwards
trajectory that you get from those very
good um samples and like I said you can
also play um with tempering the reward
distribution uh as in um as in replica
exchange for example or the uh
temperature conditional
paper so what thing should you do it's
uh the first rule is just don't do one
policy like this is just don't do this
but besides this is not so clear uh you
just start basically I think the easiest
thing to do is just start out with
Epsilon no noisy or tempering this works
for a lot of settings like it really
works for a lot of settings for things
that are getting harder you might need
to start being a bit more smart maybe
try something like um jfn or Thompson
sampling or if you're feeling brave try
your own uh new like uncertainty method
or intrinsic reward or take something
off the shelf from RL it might work um
if you do have a data set you should use
it mixing and training trajectory is
sampled from back policy is quite
powerful and is very useful if you have
access to samples which in some cases we
do all right so that is exploration now
what is the um what is the next thing is
we have data we've generated a bunch of
data from our exploratory policy how do
we choose what data we're actually going
to train on so let's say we generated a
banch of trajectories from our Behavior
policy
how do we choose which of these
trajectories to train on right so
there's been a bit of research into this
and right now there's basically three
options the first is just don't use a
buffer just take the batch of
trajectories train on it second that
people do commonly is take a standard
like uniform first and first out buffer
as an RL and the third thing that people
have done
um is is take again a first and first
out buffer and try to prioritize based
on reward people have also tried a bit
uh prioritizing based on um the loss but
I think the results on this areis less
welled at this point um so reward
prioritized buffers this is uh from a
paper with Emanuel and nille uh and also
in a paper with Andre naika uh from
20122 um and so here the idea is we have
a a batch or we have a bunch of
trajectories and States uh in a buffer
and we can try to prioritize those
States
which have higher like or higher higher
reward um and train on these more than
other things and so the specific scheme
that most uh of these reward prioritized
buffers have done is basically take the
top Alpha quantile of Rewards or objects
with rewards in the buffer and choose
beta percent of your training batch from
this and one minus beta percent from the
rest of your buff there's other ways you
can do this you can just sample
um proportional to the reward and the
buffer these things also can work but
this can be pretty useful um
specifically it's been found in for
example Manual's paper that basically if
you do this um you will converge to uh a
good value perhaps faster and in some of
nik's work that you can discover more
modes but it does come with caveats
right um You have to be careful with how
you're doing this if if you do this
naively if you make it too in a sense
greedy choose too much too big of a beta
or make the top percent too small say
you're only training on the top 05% you
can run into a very myopic policy you
can end up with Mo collapse again um and
so there are things you can do you can
try to um you could try to add in some
measure of diversity in how you're doing
this um maybe in your insertion strategy
or in your sampling strategy from the
buffer or you can just play with the
hyperparameters but you have to be
careful I mean imagine right like if
you're just choosing the best things
you're just GNA start keep choosing the
best things and you might Mo collapse so
this can be very useful for training
just make sure you're not doing the
wrong thing just make sure the things
you're doing or the results you're
getting are making some
sense okay so wrapping
up for exploration what should we do
steer away from doing on policy learning
start with just simple exploration
things just like an RL do Epsilon noisy
and tempered things if this doesn't work
try out more RL like um exploration
methods like Gil Nets which try to do
intrinsic rewards Thompson sampling
which tries to do uncertainty or
genuinely you could try many different
RL things that people have done for
uncertainty and it may work out pretty
well um
for replays uniform buffers don't seem
to have help all that much there's been
some results um on this I think just in
general people have not seen a huge
difference between just using a uniform
buffer
um just youing a uniform buffer versus
just training on the batch of
trajectories you've generated perhaps if
you try to add in something around
diversity you might get some better um
making sure you're not like forgetting
modes um but just vanilla uniform fifo
buffers don't seem to help much but re
prioritized buffers do seem to help so
try them just make sure you're not doing
something that's making your policy
die so yeah happy training a couple
quick helpful things just small things
that can make a big difference um that
are not related to exploration or replay
buffers so stabilizing learning this can
be a big deal especially as your rewards
become very big so for example if we
want to do search we want to make some
of our rewards very big especially if a
very big search space you have to do it
otherwise you just won't sample your
even if your gonet converges to the
right thing it won't sample what you
want um so you in some cases just need
to make your reward very very nons
smooth for search to work and so in
these cases you can start running into
issues with with stability um gradient
clipping is critical on some problems
you might have to play around with
hyperparameters um using delayed Network
um to can help training so using EMA on
uh exponential moving average on model
weights can be useful there's recent
work on target networks to help
stabilize things um and so on another
thing that I forgot to put on here and
I'm just remembering um normalizing the
reward making sure trying to get your
reward into As Nice of a scale that you
can under the constraints that you have
can be quite important um and another
trick we've found that can sometimes
help a lot um when specifically you have
a very re uh low reward
um very low reward temperature uh te so
this means basically your reward is
going to be very spiky because you're
dividing reward by this temperature
right so maybe it's one E5 or or
something and so it means your reward
gets very spiky rescaling the loss by um
the temperature to some some exponent
maybe one can be critical for not making
everything blow up um so yeah that's it
if people have questions I am happy to
answer
them I have a question about the
expiration strategy talked about you
briefly mentioned count count based
expiration and random networ
distillation usually these techniques
assignment reward at the current state
but for Gil we only assign rewards at
the terminal state so my question is
when you're if you have a trajectory do
you estimate that exploration reward
along along along the trajectory or just
the terminal state or at every C than
for propagated you can uh actually in
the ga fet paper one of the
contributions is to be able to use
intermediate rewards and help this for
um sampling um so you can do this it
might help your problem I think it's
problem dependent if it helps versus
even just using the reward or account
based exploration on the terminal States
but you can do this if you're interested
check out the gfm paper thank
you I was just
wondering which methods would you
prioritize in a situation where you know
in advance that all the trajectories you
have available for training start
wrong something exploratory I suppose
something exploratory I mean you could
start out with something with a very
large value of a very exploratory
Epsilon nois or tempered policy you can
I mean all these exploration things have
hyper parameters that control how
exploratory they are like I would start
with higher and you can always anneal
your exploration parameters down as you
go like so start high be be be
exploratory and
then hi hi like uh when I think in this
slide in this session like you pre
assume that reward functions are kind of
known right but let's say like reward
functions are unknown and we need to
learn from data in that case like should
we add more bonus term like coming from
a certainty of like unknown reward
functions that's an interesting question
I'm not sure I have a good answer
um so you mean like inverse problem
settings or you thinking in like energy
based modeling settings where you're
trying to learn an
energy uh I'm just considering a kind of
setting when the our reward is unknown
and we need to learn from the
data I think it's not at least to me
it's not clear I would say try things
try a bunch of different values maybe
coia seems like you might have an
idea
yeah if I may make a little comment on
that there have I've seen a few settings
where you learn the reward either
because the reward is given by
likelihood under a generative model or
as an energy based model where your
estimate of the reward function starts
out really smooth and when the reward
function starts really smooth it's
easier to learn the policy to mat
and um as the reward function evolves
and becomes spikier it becomes harder to
explore and in this setting actually
exploration is a lot less important
because it's easier without exploration
to match a very smooth smooth reward
function and as as a reward function
becomes peier you gradually settle into
the
modes but I suppose it always depends on
the specific problem at
hand great can I ask another question
like uh I remember that the so like
there is a kind of analogy for like Q
learning and also like flow matching
objective right and are there any like
the similar Concepts to like which uh
analog us to like a policy gradients
stuff uh I think there is actually a
very recent work somebody else might be
more familiar but I think there was a
recent work submitted uh
to IE clear maybe on policy gradient
with G Nets I think there's there's
recent work on this if you look it up it
should be around okay thank
you thank you Jared for the talk um you
mentioned earlier that there was this
connection uh between TB and you know
reverse K is there a similar connection
that you're aware of for replay buffers
between a different
Divergence different averages different
Divergence like for example I don't know
like that it's not purely like a reverse
scale anymore right it would be like
some different Divergence maybe like a
mix between you know forward and
backward or some maybe yeah we thought
about this a bit I mean I think so right
I mean you well you can imagine you try
to do important sampling from your
buffer and then you could say I I have
the forward like kale but then of course
you have to important sample like um
there might be interesting ways to I
haven't Maybe thought ifia has thought
about it we can talk about it after
there might be interesting ways to try
to think of like other divergences
besides you know something where you
have to important sample maybe you do
have to important sample I don't know
[Music]
um I think I think I have tried at some
point some important sampling um
experiments but I don't remember what
happened to
them thanks
yeah
Co
right well thank you
everybody
you